attack sequencing is one type of high
throughput sequencing technology used to
determine chromatin accessibility attack
stands for assay for transposes
accessible chromatin followed by
sequencing
so ataxique is really useful because the
number of cells required to perform
ataxic is really low it is highly
efficient cost effective and the time
requirement is really less so it's a
quite quick process
a toxic use
several enzymes to determine the
accessibility of Chromatin chromatin can
be less accessible or more accessible
and accessibility of Chromatin matters
because
transcription factors polymerase that
needs accessibility to start
transcribing a gene
and hence for overall transcription
accessibility of Chromatin is a key
factor
ataxic use a high active transposes
known as tn5 transposes which is
engineered with sequencing
adapters like I5 adapters or i7 adapters
in this case we have to understand the
tn5 transposers would gain accessibility
into the chromatin
if there is access if the chromatin is
heterochromatinized then tn5 would not
get access and cannot do its job but
anyway imagine a scenario where a
particular portion of the chromatin is
relatively accessible and tn5 sit there
so obviously it would chop off the
fragment and attach the sequencing
adapters so there would be several
sequencing adapters like these all these
sequencing adapters would be
forming a library which would be
sequenced using these high throughput
sequencing machine
so at the end of attack sequencing we
would be ultimately getting these kind
of sequences most likely these sequences
are coming from those regions which are
accessible to tn5 transposes and hence
more accessible in general
so there would be many of these
sequences known as reads those sequence
reads are actually aligned with respect
to the genome and specific algorithm
helps to call a peak the peak would talk
about the accessibility so Peak is kind
of a indirect readout of how many
numbers of sequences are coming from
that particular region if there are more
accessible region there would be more
reads and there would be a bigger Peak
so if we imagine that in terms of a
chromatin when we get a peak we have to
understand that particular region was
more accessible and that's why tn5 can
go there and do its job
now the question is where do we see the
ataxic peak and that determines the gene
regulation itself we might see a toxic
peak in the enhancer promoter introns 5
Prime utr and each of these
accessibility in each of these regions
might have different outcomes
anyway so let's talk about what happens
during these accessibility changes let's
say you have a
accessibility in a promoter so the
transcription Factor can jump in
interact with polymerase and start the
transcription so chromatin accessibility
is the precursor for transcription to
occur
now let us imagine there are two
different cell types and in two
different cell types there could be
different organization of Chromatin so
we can get that idea of that by the help
of attack seek so the ataxic peak would
tell us in which cell chromatin for a
particular Gene a is let us say
accessible or inaccessible in this case
we can see the gene a and the associated
chromatin is more accessible in neurons
whereas the same gene a and its
chromatin is less accessible in the
fibroblast
and along with this we can already gain
an idea that whether Gene a would be
activated or inactivated in these two
cell types
so the ataxic peak is really important
in terms of understanding that now not
only different cell types imagine a cell
type is differentiating so let's say you
have a stem cell that gets to that gets
differentiated into a skin cell via a
transition state and let's say there is
a determinant Gene of stem cell that
ultimately has to shut off in these
differentiated lineages
now that Gene is Gene X
so how come the gene X is activated in
the stem cell and inactivated in the
other cells it is also possible that the
accessibility across this chromatin is
different between the cell types and
atoxic Peak would tell us for example
here we can see the accessibility of
this particular Gene X around the
promoter is very high
whereas for other two cell types we can
see the accessibility is low across the
promoter and that defines why there is
less transcription
in these two differentiated cells
compared to the stem cell itself
now a toxic is often combined with
several other methodologies such as chip
seek or rna-seq let's say there are
again the example of two different cell
types neuron and fibroblast
now along the gene a we should
understand how the accessibility changes
so we should look at the attack Peaks
also if we have a hypothesis in our mind
that transcription factor x is sitting
in the promoter and leading to
transcription then we should also look
at the chip Peaks
the chip sequencing P could tell us
whether tell us about the transcription
Factor occupancy
and if we combine this data with the RNA
seek which talks about the expression
level of a particular Gene would give us
a holistic picture about transcription
and overall transcription Dynamics and
that is achieved by the multi-ohmics
approach when we combine chip seek
ataxic and rna-seq together
so I hope this was useful if you like
this video give it a good thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
you can get more notes and flashcards in
my Facebook page or Instagram page don't
forget to follow me also you can support
the channel by clicking on the super
thanks option you can pay via paytm UPI
or PayPal
see you in next week